sarà sensi difende lui che questo nuovo
video che sono felice oggi sia tempi sul
giro che esser perché fatto il simbolo
di una pagina che non lo so ragazzi
nello scorso episodio ho fatto un posti
a caso nel mondo è stato difficile oggi
facciamo le figure di merda in italia
prodotti per l'alitalia play vediamo
quante figure di merda di scampare
allora ragazzi
so che molti di voi si ritroveranno a
conoscere questi posti anzi la maggior
parte non mi cazzate sono una sega in
geografia soprattutto in italia garda sa
siamo a garda lamon garda perché
richiamare un negozio garda se non è a
garda valigia ivrea ma va siete scemi ma
il pontevecchio ad ivrea non sa che
quello che sappiamo intesa non son cazzo
alle piemonte figo non so niente del
piemonte figuracce dell'italia
ma è possibile che non conosca una sega
d'italia ma niente per com'è possibile
pauline foligno cazzo è politico che lo
so aiutami che sei un mio fan to malizia
voi che siete di polino che mi state
strappando gli occhi dalle orbite lo so
sono così io sono stupido raga non lo so
dove polino facciamo qui o cercere c'è
quasi foligno era era foligno poi alla
fine ho letto male vabbè porca vacca non
c'è verso bomber quanta solitudine in
una foto solo la mio dio è questo
surreal power quando vai in vacanza
sempre così a norcia giudizio dice
gollum sugli scogli è bellissimo c'è
dubbio
non ho idea di dove miglia se ti dico
sardegna perché no non lo so non è né
sardegna era minchia in calabria
mi chiedevo rivoluto avanti e guardare
in calabria ma questo sta al telefono
staff dava premi che la pre comoda
tesoro tranquillo la barba magari
possiamo anta pallavicina un cartello
così non faccio figure di merda mi dava
tranquilli e fate caso le volete lisi
loro due non sora grande operista nome
non so che cita è può essere qualsiasi
roba bella che pieno di gente che mi
segue qui sono sicuro mi stanno mandando
del peggio madonna anzio perfetto
trapani fantastico proprio una dolce tra
una sega ah beh allora adesso sì che
sono tranquillo però vedo le scarpe le
scarpe sono belle le apprezzo e cefalù
che poi è difficile sbagliare di così
tanto cibo posto sbagliato di mezza
italia
bamako se mi concentro faccio così
schifo ci in un videogioco capite ma
esistono sti posti in italia i melody
noi siamo ti prego dammi una mano per il
c'è scritto sul cartello verde parco
naturale trek lime o trentino quanti
parchi naturali
ecco le tre cime trascinava da leggere
tre cime madonna guarda guarda guarda
solo azzeccato già quello gesù grazie
tre chilometri ma conte il nostro parco
va bene va bene va bene rispetto a tutte
le figure di merda che ho fatto vabbè
però modo che figo puglia me la sento
puglia bell anche tipo torre mozza
perfetto me la sentivo proprio di merda
ti dovevi era gaeta sono prestato a
gaetano barbera champagne nazareth
betlemme non sono lorenzi lorenzi grazie
grazie che mi fate i monumenti giro
trentino trentino perché il trentino è
importante quote che non è il trentino
proprio meno vedi che la trama paragrafo
finalmente provare un posto finalmente
di mare di montagnino viste poche qua
pronto dell'italia che grossa abbastanza
grossa come il trentino voi dovete
metterli porca eva non l'ho mai non ci
sono mai stato il trentino trentino c'è
il mare non me ne frega rientranti non
lo so qua o minchia guarda c'è una
boccata d'aria fresca ve lo giuro milan
ha buon dio li va bene va bene
oh mio dio gesù grazie grazie gesù mi
con loro non sono un vero torinese non
lo ricordo più questa area dove lo staio
porca vacca tozza infame dichiarano si
vabbè mi chiedete troppo em all entrata
vabbè adesso non ci allarghiamo
come cazzo 76 metri perché era va bene
ma ben amica attaccate viasto pesce
eravamo a tono a questa roba fighissima
cioè quel cartello mi avvicino c'è altro
cartello lacorazza città di teramo la
madre chiamo dove minchia e teramo
teramo teramo teramo teramo teramo
teramo per loro porta madonna per fare
un borgo chiamato porta madonna che poi
mi sa che pure questo tra l'altro non
basta porta madonna piazza della libertà
cioè non è che credo sia questo in
teoria non lo so però vabbè tanto siamo
a terra non vivere qua grande più o meno
non è vero un chilometro proporta
madonna mi aveva dichiarato forte bello
siamo fuori dal tunnel bellissimo chiede
la scritta parte i temi sul muro siamo
fuori dal tunnel è geniale
però mentre nel tunnel vediamo adesso sì
che lo so ah sì adesso è chiaro adesso è
chiarissimo porca vacca e la madonna sia
finiti ciglia pensa sicilia non so
sicilia tcs girò un ultimo tentativo
cefalù grandeur a napoli porca vacca
va bene che all'ultima l'ultima vi giuro
ce ne andiamo anche a cercare italy
l'ultima one
ragazzi io spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto mi piace fare questi video
sull'italia perché amo il mio paese
quindi sono convinto di saper portare
onore dignità a questo è il fatto di
sapere i luoghi dove mimì collocano
fantastica ragazzi spero che i video vi
sia piaciuto come si vede ci sono molto
più mi piace anche ad iniziare c'erano
sempre scritti iscrivetevi era ci
vediamo al prossimo video mi scuso con
tutti quelli che abitavano nei luoghi
che si sono visti che si siamo andati
frustate
non è colpa mia io c'ho provato su messo
tutta la buona volontà arredo giuro però
non è da ragazzo
[Musica]